puiser et à bout à cause de la crise
sanitaire en première ligne face au co
vide comme les internes en médecine
aujourd'hui hommage silencieux rendu à
ceux qui se sont suicidés devant le
ministère de la santé à paris à l'appel
de lys ni de l'intersyndicale nationale
des internautes invités on est
secrétaire général est né en direct de
ce rassemblement
williams bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous aujourd'hui
pourquoi vous êtes devant le ministère
de la santé bonjour bain tout d'abord
comme vous l'avez indiqué pour rendre
hommage à nos collègues qui se sont
suicidés là les saints qui s'était
suicidé depuis le 1er janvier s'est fait
en tout les 18 jours c'est un nombre qui
à peu près stable depuis au moins trois
ans sans que rien ne soit fait dont
convenait d'abord leur accorder ce
moment pour vraiment les faire exister
sur la place publique parce que c'est
des morts inutiles dont on n'a pas assez
parlé
et quel est le quotidien des internes en
médecine aujourd'hui depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire ça
le modus operandi a un peu changé mais
nos conditions de travail sont déjà
assez catastrophique pour ne pas pouvoir
devenir plus catastrophique
donc on a des horaires à rallonge ses 58
heures en moyenne par semaine pour bien
ternes lambda 70 en chirurgie des
pointes à senteur ou 120 heures par
semaine pour certains donc c'était
difficile de faire plus avec le co vide
alors certes notre activité sont eux
réorganiser en termes de types de
passions qu'on peut être amené à traîner
mais d'une façon générale on bosse trop
on bosse trop depuis longtemps ces
années les gens à bout ça mais les gens
incapables de résister aux pressions de
l'environnement et donc le ca d amen je
suis finalement cette crise sanitaire a
mis en lumière des problèmes déjà
existants depuis longtemps
[Musique]
exactement ça c'est à dire que c'est un
remy l'hôpital dans la discussion
publique dans la discussion sociale par
exemple les dernières présidentielles
personne n'avait parlé de santé donc la
grâce aux colis de l'hôpital est revenu
et donc c'est pour nous le moyen de
parler de nos morts de parler de nos
conditions de travail de parler du
harcèlement qui est en grain et
systématisée à l'hôpital avec des
agresseurs qui ne sont jamais renvoyé
devant les tribunaux enfin à titre
personnel mois l'étudiant en médecine
j'ai vu une interne se prendre le foie
d'un malade dans la figure au bloc
opératoire donc c'est ça le genre de
violence contre les subir on considère
qu'on a trois pour cent de personnes qui
ont subi un viol et 14% et agression
sexuelle au cours de leurs études
médicales graves mais de notre côté avec
421 qui ont déjà fait une tentative de
suicide 23% qui ont des idées
suicidaires
c'est un état catastrophique on dénonce
et qu'on dénonce en entendant des
mesures simples qui sont juste
l'application de la loi 10 apparaît un
peu triviale mais c'est ça on me
demandait ce que notre maximum horaires
soient respectés est ce que toutes les
personnes coupables d' agissions
potentiellement heureusement d'un délit
ou d'un crime soit le transférer aux
tribunaux parce que pour l'instant tout
est géré en interne en médecine nous
vient laver son linge sale en famille et
donc les agresseurs ont continué
d'agresser de patiner
merci d'avoir effet avec une fois en
direct sur rt france william heinz vous
êtes secrétaire général de lys ni
l'inter syndicale nationale des internes
et qui rendent un hommage silencieux
aujourd'hui aux internes en médecine qui
se sont suicidés mercière